welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's track on Life Sciences
it's my pleasure to introduce to you dr.
Dino De Carlo who is a professor of
bioengineering
and serves as vice chair of the
department and as the director of the
cancer nanotechnology program in the
Johnson Comprehensive Cancer Center at
the University of California Los Angeles
dr. de Carlos research pioneered the use
of inertial fluid dynamic effects for
the control separation and analysis of
cells in microfluidic devices his recent
work extends into numerous other fields
of biomedicine and biotechnology
including directed evolution of cells
cell analysis for rapid Diagnostics
Meccano medicine next-generation
biomaterials and phenotypic drug
screening he has also been a leader in
technology entrepreneurship having
co-founded five companies that are
commercializing UCLA intellectual
property developed in his lab for a
complete biography on our speaker please
visit the biography tab at the top of
your screen dr. de Carlos keynote
presentation is titled quantum
Diagnostics from single cells to single
molecules my name is Judy O'Rourke and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots laberd's is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
and type your questions into the drop
down box our speaker will respond to
your questions via email following the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the ask a question box to let us know
that you're experiencing a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your cred
it's now about further ado please join
me in welcoming dr. Dino DiCarlo I will
now turn the presentation over to him
thank you for the introduction and it's
my pleasure to share the work we're
doing on quantum diagnostics and so the
reason we are saying that we're using
the word quantum Diagnostics is that
we're looking at the ultimate levels of
information content in biology and so
that's at the level of individual cells
and individual molecules like individual
nucleic acids and individual proteins
and so now we have the capabilities to
measure up this ultimate limit and a lot
of that has been enabled by microfluidic
technology and so what I'm going to talk
about today is what I think is the next
step and and and moving beyond
microfluidic technology to make these
Diagnostics at the ultimate limits of
biology more available and and adopted
across clinical diagnostics and research
and life sciences so you know I've
worked for a long time in the micro
fluidics space and you know we've done a
number of work a number of different
types of work in this area and here's
one example of a work that we've done on
analyzing and developing technology to
isolate cancer cells from brought blood
using a microfluidic chip and so you
know when you look at this type of chip
in the lab setting you see the you know
these are small microfluidic devices
this is a particular device we call a
vortex trapping device but what happens
is as these types of devices translate
and although they may have very unique
capabilities and provide benefit they
start to look more like this and so this
is the VTX one liquid biopsy system that
makes use of this vortex trapping
technology based off of micro fluidics
but now you have all these control
systems you have pumps you have
Electronics you have a number of other
elements that make a larger-scale
instrument required in order to control
that really simple microfluidic device
and so even though this has unique
advantages in order to isolate for
example circulating tumor cells in this
application the ability for this to
spread across multiple labs into
clinical Diagnostics becomes more
limited because of the need to uptake to
buy new instruments to buy a new capital
equipment and so this is a general
challenge with micro fluidics is that
although we have you know ability to
make small scale devices which we think
should be low cost and easily adopted by
money when it turns out to be is that
these system these micro fluid devices
then have to be operated by much larger
scale systems and so that's a challenge
that we're working to address with with
new types of technology and so I want to
talk about power technology it
particularly makes use of one of the key
advantages of micro fluidics which is
the power of compartments and so the
idea here is that in micro fluidics one
thing that has maybe driven some of the
the killer applications and micro
fluidics whether it's single molecule
analysis or single cell analysis is the
ability to compartmentalize a larger
fluid volume and break that up into
smaller and smaller fluid volumes and as
you do that you start to see so on your
left you can see it kind of schematic
where we're showing target and non
target molecules that kind of look like
nucleic acids in this case and as you
start to break up that volume into
smaller compartments you know nano lead
or some nano liter volume compartments
what you start to see is some unique
advantages so for an example if you look
at the volume than the upper right
quadrant
you've now completely purified that
particular volume from the non target
nucleic acid and you're you have also
concentrated the target
I guess a compared to the background
volume the other key aspect is now these
small volumes let's say that you need to
create an amplified signal in order to
detect these single molecules that
amplified signal accumulates to very
high concentrations in that small volume
and enables you to detect it very easily
that also is very valuable let's say if
you have a cell that's secreting some
signal and that or your license cell and
you want to extract material from that
so that material or that secreted signal
becomes a much higher concentration in
that small volume so this has really
driven a lot of innovation in micro
fluidics and as I said some of the
killer applications and here's an
example of one application that
bio-rad has developed has commercialized
that's called
droplet digital PCR and so they're
they're kind of a few key steps here the
first step is using microfluidics to
create uniform volumes to
compartmentalize this larger volume and
again the uniformity of that volume is
also important because you want the
reactions that proceed in those volumes
to occur at the same rates and and so
that's a products that accumulate in
those volumes to be at similar
concentrations you then can run a
reaction in that volume inserting the
bio at the digit droplet digital PCR
approach you're incubating the in order
to amplify a nucleic acid using PCR and
then you read out those compartments
using some type of fluorescence
measurement based on the amplified the
signal that is accumulated in the
compartment so this looks very simple
and those others micro fluidics in some
some Rita but what it turns out is
actually in order to achieve this you
need new instrumentation as I mentioned
before so you need one instrument in
order to generate these droplets these
mono dispersed compartments and you need
another instrument so you need also a
thermal cycler in order to run PCR and
then you need a third instrument in
order to read out those droplets
and so these are all unique instruments
you need to then acquire in order to
bring this really powerful digital or
single molecule or quantum diagnostic
assays to clinical use and and so that's
a barrier because of the cost of course
to acquire the new instruments but in
even in order to try out new things
there's a large barrier that that any
new clinical lab or a researcher who's
trying to develop new assays has to
overcome to do this and you know this of
course is for one particular assay which
is a nucleic digital nucleic acid
amplification si but now if you imagine
if you want to look at single protein
molecules using digital iliza or single
cells for each of these assays you now
need new equipment so that's a big issue
so the dependence on new infrastructure
and disposables for each of these
quantum assays is a challenge for
adoption and for this really technical
technology that's out the ultimate
limits of what we can analyze and a
biological sense to reach humanity in a
larger sense this is a been a barrier so
the other the other aspect of these
compartment systems that is important
and has been a challenge is you also
want in some of these assays a solid
face or reaction so I'm showing here at
digital Eliza from the quantex MOS
system where you have a bead that is
that that has your capture antibody to
perform your single molecule Eliza you
also have in single-cell RNA seek this
is an example from the 10x genomics
system where you have a cell in a
compartment but also a bead in that
compartment that will capture the mRNA
from that lysed cell in order to do then
perform a bar coding of that mRNA and
single-cell RNA sequencing and finally
there's a number of assays that make use
of a solid phase to capture the
secretions of individual cells and this
is showing one example from chris loves
group where they're capturing cytokine
secretions from leukocytes
a surface is coated with antibodies so
the solid phase is also an important
aspect of these quantum assays okay so
the question that then arises is if we
have this area for infrastructure with
current microfluidic technologies how
can we overcome that barrier and so can
we create uniform small volumes a
uniform is key here as well and each of
those volumes having a solid phase that
that allows us to create these
compartments that are have unique
advantages but then also analyze the
output of those reactions that occur in
those compartments without a new
equipment that may be challenging you
know the new infrastructure that has to
be to be acquired and so you know the
first one one question that that I'll
ask an answer is you know what is the
highly sensitive and what is a highly
sensitive and high throughput analyzer
of fluorescence which is many of the
signals that we that we expect us to see
from these digital assays will be
fluorescent that's almost in having any
researcher or clinical lab and one
answer to this is a flow cytometry so
these are big lattice analyzers
extremely high sensitivity using
photomultiplier tubes to look at
fluorescence of single cells they can
measure multiple different colors and so
they have a lot of power and their
presence is is ubiquitous in research
labs are but also in clinical labs so
can we leverage that as our Emma
analysis platform for assets that are
occurring in these individual particles
our individual compartments okay so so
the challenge then is is not for the
reader but it is how do we create these
uniform compartments in a very simple
process and so you know you know one way
to create these compartments is with
emulsions of course there's micro Wells
and other things that are using micro
fluidics but emulsions has been really
driver of many of the applications
however if you just shake an emulsion a
shake up oil and water to create an
emulsion that emulsion is not stable its
metastable you get non-uniform drops of
many different sizes and those drops
will want to coalesce over time so can
we make an emulsion that is that you
just shake up and it creates uniform
size drops and then each of those drops
also has that solid phase that we talked
about and so that is that is the
challenge and I'm gonna answer the you
know whether we can do this you know not
hold you in suspense and the answer is
yes that we can do this and I'm going to
tell you about the technology that we've
been developing this particle drop
technology in order to to make this
happen and so it's useful to kind of
step back a bit and and think about kind
of the fundamentals of these types of
emulsion systems and one way that I like
to think about these systems is through
something I call a volume energy curve
or a ve curve if you look at the volume
energy curve for a drop of let's say
water and oil it will follow this
relationship of the energy of the
interfacial energy scaling with the
volumes to the two-thirds power and
that's because the interfacial energy
scales with the surface area and the
volume is scaling with the the with the
radius to the third power
and so what you see is this curve where
it's a the convexity of the curves is
down and so you have a convex curve for
the and this volume energy curve and
with that that convex curve means is
that those droplets will always want to
coalesce to smaller volume droplets will
want to merge to create a larger volume
droplet because that will be the minimum
and energy and so you can kind of see
you know look through this if you have a
convex curve and the volume energy
landscape and you have two droplets that
interact what you'll see is that those
draw
let's we'll start to merge to create a
bigger droplet and another smaller
droplet down to you know no droplet so
that you accumulate into one larger
volume droplet so that happens with
convexity a convex curve and in this
volume energy landscape now if you start
to add concavity to this curve that you
start to see some really interesting
effects so now two different volume
droplets that interact what they want to
do is actually go and partition evenly
to two evenly sized droplets that are
half of the total volume and so I've
drawn this volume energy curve as having
minimum the energy landscape but it's
not necessary it just has to have convex
region and a concave region and so what
you can imagine now is that you start to
have droplets that will accumulate at
this particular size so as if their
volume of the droplet is too small
they'll start to get bigger and bigger
and bigger and merge and then at some
point as they reach a larger size then
they will start to split in half and
then you can have another region that's
that's that's convex again where you
would then start to accumulate droplets
at this minima and then one big large
droplet okay so this is the strategy
that we can start to take - in order to
think about how to create mono dispersed
droplets in an energetically favorable
way of course the question then arises
how do we create in a physical sense
this type of volume energy curve and so
one way to do this is have the droplets
interact with surfaces so if you have a
droplet interact with a single surface
it will form a spherical cap on that
surface and that spherical cap allows a
certain energy landscape that actually
looks convex similar to a sphere that
convexity starts to change as you see
here when you have two surfaces
interacting any format annoyed
as the draw interacts between those two
services and so the strategy here is
adding more more interactions with these
wedding micro structures around the
droplet in order to change the convexity
so you can imagine as you add more
structure beyond two parallel planes of
surfaces then you start to bring this
curve down further and further and as it
starts to move down further and further
in order to then transition out to a
droplet that's completely full and we'll
have to that the convexity will have to
change again and so you can start to see
this so you know just to summarize kind
of how this will work is that we need
some type of structured particles to
modulate this volume energy curve so
here are two volume energy curves for a
free droplet that follows this volume to
the two-thirds power and you see a
surfactant coded droplet it still
follows this volume to the two-thirds
power the surfactant will just lower the
end of the inter facial energy but still
the droplets that are coated with
surfactants will still want to coalesce
over time however if we start to now
have a structured particle that has
these two parallel plates but also a
edge around it what you can start to see
as you modulate that volume energy curve
to have convex region at the beginning
between 1 & 3 and then a concave region
and then another convex region as you go
from 4 5 to 6 and so what I'm showing on
the bottom here are models and
simulations of how a droplet would fill
this type of particle and then the
energy the interface show the total
system energy that corresponds to these
filling States and this is if you impose
that this is the amount of volume that
has to go into the droplet so what you
can start to see is that this type of
volume energy curve if you then analyze
how this type of hollow volume would
split between two of these types of
particles what you see
is that at lower volumes we're in that
convex region and the the whole volume
will stay either in one or the other of
the particle so that's the first region
where you don't get splitting at the
droplet and so you get filling of one of
the particles and then as the volume
increases further let's say this
normalized volume of two then you can
see that the energy minimum is actually
when the volume splits evenly between
the two particles so that means that now
these particles are full and they will
split and feel that the next particle
and then if you go to even higher
volumes then you start to see that one
particle will fill completely and the
other particle will take the rest of the
volume and so that's kind of goes back
to a convex region but that's a really
the mechanism on how you can fill
particles to this this uniform control
volume in an energetically favorable way
so that you can do this with simple
mixing processes I've you okay so so we
demonstrated some of this using a model
system and the videos here are not going
to show but that that's that's fine I'll
show you some data that comes from these
videos and what you see here is that
this is a peg polyethylene glycol
internal layer and polypropylene I call
external layer so you have an internal
polymer layer that's hydrophilic and out
an outside layer of this particle that's
a bit more hydrophobic and this is the
type of particle that we're using to
generate these types of particle drops
and so if you do experiments where you
start to split the volumes between
macroscale particles so you can see the
volumes here these are particles that we
that we made using some 3d printing type
of molds you can see that at low volumes
below around 600 microliters that the
the two particles will split evenly
and you'll get an even volume to each
particle but above about six hundred
microliters one one particle will kind
of maximize what we'll get to this
maximum volume and stay there while the
other particle will take the rest of the
volume so you can imagine over large
numbers of particles that this leads to
another of these particles all holding
the same volume and then and then a
larger part a larger volume around
that's held by a one particle so that's
on the condom on the micro scale so you
can see yet there's even partitioning
and uneven partitioning at these larger
bones so that's what happens at the
sorry the macro scale so then the
question is can we make these types of
multi-material 3d structured particles
and many of them at the micro scale so
that's a challenge that you know that
we've been addressing using a technology
that we call transient liquid molding
and so this combines two technologies
one is inertial flow sculpting and the
second is an automated photo
polymerization system so an inertial
force cull thing I'll tell more about
this in following slides we make use of
the fact that around pillars we can
modulate the shape of a flow stream and
so we could Co flow to polymer
precursors and then structure those
polymer Creek precursors into a shape
like this C shape and then we can design
a mask and then we can expose those
polymer precursors to UV light for
example to photo cross-linked them and
treat the structured particle okay so
I'm going to talk a little bit about
this inertial flow sculpting because we
developed some software in order to in
order to know what types of microfluidic
devices we would need to construct in
order to create this flow sculpted shape
of interest okay so one of the
challenges with this is how do I know
what sequence of pillars are going to
create the deformation that
leads to the flow shape that I'm
interested in creating and so we used
the genetic algorithm an approach to do
optimization that's based off of
developing a chromosome of
configurations where each chromosome has
the inlet flow conditions and the pillar
sequence then leads to some phenotype
which is the outlet flow configuration
and so so here's an example you have an
inlet flow which shows the blue region
and this is a cross section of the flow
where one particular material is and
then you have a particular sequence of
pillars that is used to deform that
shape and then you have the phenotype or
the outlet flow what that shape looks
like and so we can input into this type
of algorithm you know different types of
mutants of this pillar sequence and
Inlet flow and then we see what the
outlet flow conditions are and then we
have a fitness function that says okay
how close is this to some particular
flow sheet that I'm trying to target
let's say this u-shape and then you know
that Fitness function would say you know
the top two of those shapes the diamond
leg shape and the H like shape are not
as close to the U shape as the bottom
shape so that Fitness function would
then say okay this the bottom shape is
one where we should inherit more that we
should have that chromosome stay around
mutagenize it a bit and then keep
iterating until it gets closer and
closer to the shape of interest so this
is how we optimize and solve this
inverse problem of okay if I have a
shape of interest in the flow how do i
generate the pillar sequence that will
lead to the flow deforming to create
that shape of interest so we have
developed a software called flow sculpt
this is work by a postdoc in the lab
dense top line and you can you can
download flow sculpt that this website
here and it basically gives a sum
ability to do drawing to draw the flow
shape of your interest it has then
output a character
but capabilities to output a CAD design
of the microfluidic device that would
treat that particular flow shape of
interest so how does this work so an
example that we've prepared is that you
know can flow sculpt generate these
letters for UCLA so these are the target
flow shapes and you know what are can
flow sculpt create pillar structures
that lead to these target flow ships and
so the results that you get from the
simulation are pretty good right so this
is the U you see that that matches
pretty well with the target shape you
see that here is a see here is an L and
here is an A so you know it is not
exactly the the letter Z maybe more like
the script of some serial killer or
something like that but still a pretty
good approximation of target shapes
given that we're we're manipulating the
the flow just with very blunt operators
of Pilar's in a channel and so we so I
you can really get these types of shapes
and that occurs in ways that are really
not intuitive if you're trying to design
where these pillars were in a forward
type of design process so making use of
the genetic algorithm is very critical
in getting this to work in a functional
way so business matters with what we see
experimentally the answer is pretty
pretty well so this is looking at
confocal imaging of fluorescent dye that
is flown into a channel so we're looking
at the channel cross-sections and you
see that the channel cross-sections
match pretty well with the predicted
results for these particular letters and
beyond single material so you saw this
blue material in a white background of
other flow materials we can also predict
the flow shape
for InDesign in a design pillar
combinations that lead to foil shapes of
multiple in certain materials so in this
case you see two materials and you and
our output is a diamond-shaped pattern
that has one half of the blue material
on one half of the red material and so
here's some again using for sculpt to
solve for desired flow shapes and you
can see the results on on the right so
the left is the target flow shapes of
three different material two to three
different materials red blue and green
materials and you see the flow sculpt
results on the right demonstrating the
ability to create geometries that are
similar to those materials okay
so once we had this capability to design
these types of u-shaped particles that
have an internal region containing a
hydrophilic material and the external
region having a hydrophobic material we
were able to then manufacture these
types of particles in a microfluidic
device and so of course we want to
manufacture them at small-scale and at
high throughput and so this is a
particular design for manufacturing
polyethylene glycol and polypropylene
guy called materials to create these
empathetic particle that can can hold
droplets and we use parallel masks in
order to polymerize a array of these
particles all at one time then we repeat
the process of flowing to create the
shape stopping the flow and then
cross-linking through the mask in order
to generate a number of particles and so
here's an example of the particles that
we fabricated you can see there's pretty
high uniformity in the shape of the
particles you can kind of see an
internal region that's the polyethylene
glycol that's has slightly different
contrasts than the external region which
is polypropylene glycol and you also see
the length scale here so the scale bars
500 microns and so the cavity here is in
the hunt
micron scale and those total particles
is in the if you get a few hundred
micron scale just if you zoom in a bit
more you can see you know the the both
the outer poly propylene glycol layer
and the internal pie Claire the peg
layers here dyed with a fluorescent dye
and so you can see that the internal
layer lining the particle you can also
we're showing on the bottom is a
particle of a certain dimension but by
changing your mask you could also change
the dimensions of the particles that you
polymerize so you have capability to
create three-dimensional shape particles
that have both the shape of the float
the flow stream as well as the shape of
the mass that you apply with light
through dyed that that filters the light
and so what you can create then is a
extrusion of the mask shape with the
flow stream shape and that creates your
final particle shape okay so once we
have these particles can we then make
these uniform drops just with a simple
shaking procedure right so that's the
that goal here we don't want any micro
fluidics for the end user
right micro fluidics can be used to make
these particles but the end user now
should have the ability to take the
particles that are provided to them with
their sample of interest shake it up or
pipette it up and down using kind of
standard instruments in any lab and
create the monodisperse
compartments that are the key to driving
a lot of these quantum diagnostic acids
and so what you see here is is kind of a
say you have water these particles we
call them drop carrier particles and oil
that are in the vial we then do a simple
mixing and centrifugation process and
that creates what we call particle drops
which are these particles that are
supporting the water phase internal and
this works and we see that we can create
a uniform drops and you notice that
these drops are not spherical right so
they are supported
the particle and so their lowest energy
state is not a sphere like a normal drop
in emulsion but this kind of cat I like
shape that is because their templated by
these particle particle carriers okay so
we started to study these these particle
drops a bit more and so an example one
kind of important point is is are they
monitor dispersed
do they have very uniform volumes and so
what we start to see is in in different
oils so you have been the blue and
yellow two different oils that we're
using to create these particle drops the
aqueous solution is the same and you see
that there's a mode in both of those
oils that that is really uniform
compared to a droplet that is just
stabilized by surfactant that spreads
out over orders of magnitude larger
diameters and so that's because the the
surfactant although it stabilizes a
droplet to coalescence very rapidly it
doesn't create and preferred volume that
department that drop carrier particles
do create as I mentioned that these
drops are not spherical and so you know
one key aspect is their shape and how
uniform their shape is and you can kind
of quantify these things and you see
that their shapes are also have
circularity s that are not like a sphere
not one which you see with surfactant
stabilized drops but are closer to you
know point five or depends that policy
depends on on the shape of the particle
and the filling of these these particle
drops as we saw and in the theory that
that suggests that you would create a a
mode and volume it depends on the volume
that you apply to the droplets but after
a critical volume what you start to see
is that they all start to fill that with
this mode about 200 microns for these
these particular drops that we
regenerated and these types of drops
that are formed or emulsions that have
the particles surrounding a droplet
which we're calling an armored emulsion
appear stable over many
so this is over three days and you can
see that the nominal diameter the mode
and the diameter stays very consistent
over those three days you can see the
distribution is pretty consistent over
those three days for these these
particular drops here are some pictures
that kind of showing the stability of
the drops at day 1 and day 4 we're
showing a fluorescent dye that's
staining that the volume of the fluid in
the droplet so you can see them there
are some unique features of these types
of systems and that you can prevent the
cross talk between droplets because
they're surrounded by this solid phase
so here's an example where we had two
different solutions that were created
and one had a red dye and particle
supporting droplets with the red dye and
the other solution had a green dye and
then we created these draw particle
drops that supported a green dye and
then we mix those two together we
agitated them and what we see is that
there's no cross stock we don't see
particles then that have at least wood
that have red and green and we don't see
you know loss of green or red in
droplets so there's stability but also
you don't have drops coming off and out
and in and and you don't have the the
droplets crosstalking across separate
particle drops so that's an interesting
aspect that you know may be different
than the surfactant stabilizes systems
where you may see some crosstalk that's
facilitated rather select in itself so
what can we start to do with these
particles particle drops well anything
that you can do with a micro fluid drop
basically or anything you can do with a
micro well array and so here we're
showing that kind of two examples proof
of concepts on the Left we're showing
the filling of these particle drops with
particles so in this case we chose
different sized particles which we
wanted to show that there's capability
to fill
but propulsive prevent the filling or
the encapsulation of a particle if it's
size is too big so in this case we could
encapsulate particles of different sizes
into the particle drops but if the
particle size is larger than the volume
lifts that's you know that's held by
that drop then it wouldn't be
encapsulated and on the right we're
seeing a time-lapse image of a algae
that's encapsulated and another particle
drop showing the viability of that cell
over days as it's growing and moving in
the drop we can also perform reactions
and these drops so here's an example of
a you know of an immunoassay type
reaction where we're amplifying the
presence of a protein and that amplified
presences is read using a fluorescent
marker of the of the amplified
amplification reaction and one
interesting thing we see here also is
that that amplified fluorescent marker
accumulates in the particle the region
of the particle at a higher
concentration than the aqueous portion
and so that could potentially even
amplify the the signal even further so I
think there's there's a potential here
also to leverage the reactions and what
can occur on the solid phase and aqueous
phase to improve immunoassays in these
types of systems okay so you know
understanding that these types of new
particle drop systems have these unique
capabilities we also looked in the
literature and found you know with any
good idea there are some folks that have
explored some aspects of the idea
previously and so this is work from
Richard Mathies lab where here they're
using a microfluidic device to
encapsulate cells in in agarose
particles and agarose drops that there
if I and they use those particles as a
way to template drop formation okay
of course here there's still micro
fluidics that are needed in order to put
the cell into the droplet and so that's
the part that you know this is still an
issue with with this approach but you
wanted to build off of the ability of
that they demonstrated for here a
spherical agarose particle to the hole
to template emulsion just this chimp
symbol mixing and shaking and so we've
developed a way that we could get rid of
the micro fluidics for this type of
process and so we could template a mono
dispersed emulsions by mixing shaking
spherical particles that had cavities
embedded in them so those cavities then
could hold cells where the previous
approach is you needed micro fluidics to
in order to put the cells into the
particles and so you can see here you
know this is not a micro fluidic
generated emulsion this is an emulsion
that's generated using the particle and
just mixing with simple processes and
you can see that because there's some of
the droplets that also have more than
one particle so you can see a triangular
shaped droplet that's three particles
and in a few droplets that I have two
particles together but generally this is
a you know at least a very mono
dispersed drop sizes here's a
fluorescent image of these type of
emulsion of where you see the red dye
red fluorescent dye is staining the
particle that has this cavity that holds
cells in the blue fluorescent signal is
showing the aqueous phase that's
surrounding the droplet and you can see
that you know there's pretty good
Monica's personally there and I'll show
a quantification of that in a later site
so the idea here is this what we're
calling a tropical can be used for
example in single-cell analysis
workflows so in this case we're using
this tropical to then put it into a well
plate seed cells attach the cells to the
tropical we can then use a simple
process of emulsification using pipe
to encapsulate the drops and then we can
read out some signal capture that signal
on the particle and then read it out
using standard flow cytometer and so
this is really the workflow and again
there's no microphone X there's all
processes that are standard to research
labs and clinical labs and that's really
the goal here so how do we manufacture
these types of hollow particles so we
use a aqueous two-phase system and
microphone X itself again to do the
manufacturing so here we have a peg
dextran system that then phase separates
the peg is a photo cross linkable peg
and that is after the phase separation
we can cross link that we can then wash
out the dextran as we transfer it back
to water and that gives us these shell
shaped particles so when we then create
emulsions with these particles they are
pretty mono dispersed and so you can see
and the emulsion picture of it on the
right side on the left side you can see
that we have particle drops that are
formed and you can see that there are
two regions so one are the drops that
are templated by the particles and you
know they have very uniform size TVs
around 5% which is you know it's quite
good and comparable to many microfluidic
approaches to generate droplets and then
you have satellite droplets that have
mill particles inside and those are can
be avoided because they are not I you
don't have a solid phase to capture
signal on them and so they don't will
not show up in in the final assays with
flow cytometry so cells can be loaded
into the system so you're seeing a
lifestyle stain on and particles that
are there in red and cells in green and
you can see that there they remain
viable over a period at least in
these emulsion systems particle
supported emulsions and you can load
cells just as you would in other droplet
systems following Poisson statistics
depending on really the concentration
that you apply to begin with we can then
run assays on cells that are
encapsulated in the droplets just as you
would in microfluidic or another type of
system that has a solid phase and here
we're capturing the secretion from a
cell in the droplet onto the surface of
the the particle that's creating the
droplet and then after we then bring
that back into an aqueous phase we can
then stain for the presence of that
secretion and while maintaining the cell
on that particle and then we can sort
based off of both the secretion and
aspects of the cell using standard flow
cytometry systems so this is an exciting
demonstration of how this type of
technology can be used in single-cell
analysis obviously we're at kind of
initial stages of using these types of
technologies but you know the
capabilities are there really is was
about can we create uniform droplets
with simple processes and we've also
shown that we can analyze these types of
particles with flow cytometer so here's
the question that I and really the
direction that we're going we're going
from this idea of lat on a chip which
you know there is a chip but around that
chip there's a lot of infrastructure and
instruments and so that leads to a
barrier and adopting new technologies
and trying out new technologies in the
clinical labs as well as in research
settings when we're going from that lab
on a chip to lab on a particle and
that's really driven by this economic
approach to make mono dispersed droplets
just by simple shaking operations then
these types of droplets the signals from
the droplets can be captured on
particles that can
red with standard flow cytometry and so
you avoid the need for new
instrumentation new infrastructure on
that side of things as well and that
solid phase I think is particularly
interesting because now you can do new
engineering of that solid phase and that
will open up new opportunities for what
I'm calling lab on a particle systems
and I think these lab on a particle
systems can help accelerate our
understanding and our of life science so
it has a life science research tool for
example discovery of biological rare
elements as we look at single nucleic
acids and single proteins that might be
present in different disease states as a
way to do single-cell analysis at a much
higher rates and a lower lower cost so
for these human cell Atlas type
applications but across also a number of
applications in health and energy and
environment in creating new approaches
to evolve cells or other products based
on sorting based on secretions or other
aspects that can accumulate and be
measured in these types of small
compartments so I think that there's
going to be a lot of new technology
developments that are needed to as we
advance these lab line of particle
systems and one of the key metrics that
will start to I think pay attention to
is really the number of single cells or
molecules that we can analyze in an
experiment and so maybe this is our next
metric similar to Moore's law on
transistors that we should be paying
attention to is and I think that the
technology will accelerate rapidly using
these types of lab on particle systems
so that we can get orders of magnitude
higher numbers of single cells and
single molecules really this quantum
level of information that that is the
key to understanding biology and
understanding disease processes so with
that I'm happy to acknowledge really the
the
Tribute ears from my lab and as well as
our collaborators to have laid the
foundations for this new approach at
which I'm extremely excited about and I
think you've the audience for listening
and will be happy to answer questions
through the online process thank you
very much thank you dr. DeCarlo for that
informative presentation I would also
like to thank laberd's for making
today's educational webcast possible as
a final reminder our speaker will follow
up with any questions you've submitted
via email that is all for now thank you
for joining us we'll see you next time
goodbye